[Music]
I'm a data scientist for an e-commerce
company and I've been asked by my
management to help the marketing team
develop a group of Target audiences for
their next campaign they've requested
that customers be split into five groups
based on order behaviors and for some
descriptive statistics about each group
to do this I'll create and summarize a
cayman's clustering model and possibly
even create a visualization for it using
the available e-commerce data we
have additionally I'd like to take it
one step further and see if I can
provide the marketing team with some
actionable next steps to take with each
of these groups to streamline and speed
up their work efforts a bit using duet
AI I'm hopeful that I'll be able to do
all this and take that extra step
without too much additional time needed
from my end I'll need to use big Cy
Studio to complete my task so first I
need to enable it starting in the Google
Cloud console I'll go to the bigquery
page and I can see in the lower leftand
corner there's a popup that says try new
code management features of Bakery
studio in
preview note that you may or may not see
this depending on when you're accessing
Bakery Studio as it may be out of
preview by the time that you check it
out so I'll click enable now a list of
required apis will appear and I'll click
enable all skip the permission section
and enable all of the additional apis as
[Music]
well back in big Cruise Studio at the
top of the page I'll click this drop-
down arrow and select compose new python
notebook you'll have to choose a region
to store your code assets from the
dropdown and click select a new sample
notebook will will pop up with some
example cells which you can check out if
you want but I'm actually going to
delete them so I can use this notebook
for my task to do this I can click the
garbage can icon that appears when I
hover over each cell now I'll need to
connect to a runtime in the upper right
hand corner of the notebook I'll click
the drop down and select connect to a
runtime then select create a new
runtime leave the
default and click connect
that can take a little while if it's
your first time connecting to a runtime
or if it's been more than a few hours
since you last connected if it's taking
some time I can still move on to the
next step which is creating a big query
data
set to do that I can click the three
dots next to my project in the Explorer
Pane and select create data set I'll
name the data set e-commerce and select
the multi- region location type
and US multiple regions in the United
States click create data set and I can
see in the Explorer pane that my data
set has been created now back in the
notebook I'm going to start pasting in
some code that I have prepared to import
the necessary libraries Define the
variables are used in the upcoming steps
and initiate the connection for big
query and vertex AI to add code into the
notebook I'll click this Plus Code
button that appears when I hover at the
top of the
window and the first set of code I'll
paste in is to import the necessary
libraries next I'll paste in some code
to define the variables like data set
name model name and table name and to
initiate the bigquery and vertex AI
connection now my runtime is connected
which I know because I can see this
green check mark in the upper corner
here so I can run these code cells by
click clicking the play button to the
left of each cell I can click multiple
at once and it'll just cue them
up my initial steps are complete so next
I can create and import a base table as
a big query data frame this table will
serve as my base table moving forward
and the doit AI magic here will allow me
to run big query SQL right from a
notebook cell so again I'll create a new
code cell
and paste in my
code
and run it now I'll use the generate AI
feature by adding a new code cell and
clicking generate with AI I want to
create a big query data frame with the
table I just created and have it show me
the top 10 records and all I have to do
is insert a natural language prompt with
the table I want
referenced and hit enter so here we go
it's generated some code for me to use
this looks right so I'm going to go
ahead head and run the
code and boom I can see the data frame
output displayed right here in my
notebook now that I was able to get my
customer data in a big query data frame
I can create a c's clustering model to
split the customer data into clusters
based on different variables like
recency order count and spend and then
visualize the data in a new code cell
I'll use the generate with AI feature
again and enter a prompt asking for a
few things first for the data frame to
be split into test and training data for
a c's clustering algorithm second to
create a k means clustering model with
five
clusters and lastly as to save the model
to Big
query press enter and see what it gives
me great so it popped out some code and
it has the steps that I want with what
looks like the right code so I'll run
[Music]
it and now my model should be created if
I refresh the content of my Explorer
panel by clicking the three dots and
refresh content the model should pop up
under my e-commerce data set there it is
customer segmentation model under the
e-commerce data set the next step is to
define a new big query data frame that
joins the segment or cluster produced by
the camans model back to the original
data so again we'll use the generate
with AI feature and enter a prompt to
create a new data
frame again some nice code output looks
good so I'll run
it now that my job is finished I want to
double check that this cluster column
has actually been added to my data set
so I'll run this code quickly to show me
the top 10 records again like I did
before and I can see here in the table
that the cluster column has been
[Music]
added so now we can create a basic
visualization to see what the data looks
like I'll go for a scatter plot using
the predictions data frame I created to
look at the relationship between the
days since last order by average sprend
and colored by cluster which was just
generated using our camian
model so I'll prompt generate with AI to
generate a scatter plot and I'll tell it
what to put on each AES as well as a
title attribute grouped by C's
[Music]
cluster okay it gives me the output I'll
double check that everything looks
good and run the
code
[Music]
and there it is the scatterplot visual
attributes grouped by C's cluster with
average spend on the y- AIS and danon's
last order on the
x-axis it's pretty awesome that I can
split my data into clusters and
visualize it right here inside this
python notebook in bigquery Studio but
let's take it that one step further and
use the magic of llms to really help the
marketing team with their
campaign we can use the cluster
information to ask the llm for help
generating insights on each
cluster to do this first we'll need to
summarize the Clusters so we can see
what they look like in a new code cell
I'll paste this code that defines a new
data frame which displays some summary
statistics for each of the
[Music]
Clusters and I'll run
it okay so already just from looking at
the results here I can immediately glean
some insights from the
table I have five clusters and I can see
some clusters have a higher spend While
others have a higher count of orders and
[Music]
more this is great information but it's
a lot of metrics and cluster info so I'm
going to use some code to convert the
data frame into a string so that I can
pass it into the llm
call so I'll run
this it'll give me this output that is
in a string format and is called cluster
info as I defined in my
input now I can take this cluster info
and use it to Define Define a
prompt so that the llm text bison knows
what I'm asking for so to Define this
prompt I'll paste in some code that says
this information will be referred to as
prompt and then what I want from the
model in this case I'll say it's a
creative brand strategist and given the
following clusters it should come up
with a Persona title and next marketing
action for each cluster using that
cluster info that was previously created
then I'll run
[Music]
it and there won't be an output because
I'm just defining the variable called
prompt that I'll use to call the
llm so so far we've created a cayman's
model assigned each customer a cluster
from the
model generated summary statistics for
each cluster and defined a prompt with
my prompt defined I can now call the
text bison model to generate customer
insights and next steps for the
marketing campaign using generate with
AI I'll enter a prompt to call the tech
bison model and have it generate a
marketing campaign using the variable
prompt that I just defined it gives me
an output which looks good so I'll run
it
[Music]
and
awesome okay this is really cool there's
information about each cluster
title Persona and next marketing step
for each cluster like a personalized
email or a special offer and it's in a
format that is easily sharable with the
marketing team normally it would take
hours of manual work to gather
customized information accounting for
Taste spend and buy frequency as a data
scientist
now I was able to do this in minutes by
combining generative AI with the data in
bigquery make sure to check out the
links in the description to learn more
about getting started with duet Ai and
bigquery
[Music]
Studio